Hello Freak bitches on the weekends,
if I'm off the road,
I go to coffee places to sit and write for hours and work on book manuscripts
and all by the small coffee like this one and three and a half hours later I'll
leave and I just drop it in the trash because it's still about three quarters
full,
so I don't drink a lot of coffee in the wintertime.
I'll drink a cup of tea in the morning and have a cup,
a part of a cup of coffee.
I'll drink all of the tea.
What,
what makes what?
What fuels you to be so prolific?
You know you're saying you write an article a month for the La weekly was so
once a week.
A thousand words a week?
Yeah.
Which does not do that.
You write for rolling stone author Australia once a month and then I write,
I try and write a thousand words a day for myself and I have right now five
different books in various states of completion and that's not some College Guy
Saying my manuscript,
these are,
they're done and I'm by day.
I edit,
I'm editing.
The next journal book,
Travel Book and then at night I'm writing a,
another journal book and working on one of two different music books.
I do a series of music books called fanatic where I,
you know,
rare records and labels like music geek stuff and so I work on those at night.
And you also host a radio show and I have the weekly radio show I just filled
in.
Oh,
tomorrow in England and BBC radio six.
I'm filling in for iggy pop.
He took a vacation from his show,
so I filled in for him last week and this week as well.
So I did those shows.
So I'm.
I'm always busy and so stimulants would get in my way.
What powers me.
It's not money,
it's not ambition,
it's anger.
I'm one of those people.
I,
I wish there was a better way to say it,
but it's,
it's vengeance.
He laughed at me in high school,
man.
He said I was going to be anything really like watch this,
like that.
Still pushing you in 56.
I hate to say it.
Oh yeah,
40,
40 years later.
Oh yeah.
All of it.
Like,
you know,
my dad,
he was a big money guy.
I'm like okay,
you love money so much watching me outgrows you and your whole damn family to
combined and I don't,
I don't even care about it.
I just like achieving it and it's one of the reasons when the agent goes,
okay,
five shows on one off.
I'm like,
oh no,
no man,
no,
that's a day off.
You put a show in there.
Like why?
Because like,
screw that man,
watch me put two shows on that night.
What you think I can't.
I'm just,
like I said,
I set up adversarial relationships.
I'm not against you or anything.
I'm just saying like I have to have something to push against.
Like a schedule that is like the schedules,
like Godzilla.
Like you can't finish this all like really man,
I'm going to serve you up and eat you every day like a steak and I just have to
have that.
And so I'm getting back and it's A.
I think of all the people I was in bands with,
I have to crush them.
Everyone grew up with,
I have to powderize them.
Why that's such a weird motivation is it sucks immature.
It's like it's 11 year old sandbox.
Wow.
Like you're aware of it,
which makes it even stranger because it's not something that you're just
operating under know it's controlling you and you don't understand why I quite
enjoy it.
Yeah.
Like if I,
you know,
I,
I'm not an actor but I go for acting parts on bike basically going in there and
winging it and I get,
you know,
I get to go up for like really big parse this a little bit of trepidation
knowing I'm going in there.
But then I think like,
oh yeah,
Sony,
whatever,
man.
Line it up and almost like run out of my car.
Like you know where you at Man?
And I'm not trying to impress you.
I'm a tough guy because I'm not.
I just need,
it just needs to be trying to tell me I can't and I that informs
everything I do.
Like instead of just dialing my radio show in,
I will work on that sucker for like five hours.
It has to be all handpicked.
Know that song,
not that one,
this one,
and they make like three drafts of it.
It's intense.
It's one of the reasons why I live alone.
It's like I work all the time like,
hey,
come out on this week and now it's 7:00 PM on a Friday.
I'm working like I'm not constant.
Yeah,
no,
I'm not fun to hang out with.
Do you vacation ever where you just chill?
I can't intellectually and existentially.
I can't understand the idea of a vacation.
I make a joke on stage and said I want to come back 10 pounds lighter with an
internal parasite.
I,
I want to come back with a scar where the spear kind of grazed me and eight
grade stories and a dangerous insect in my bag.
I don't want to sit on the beach and soak in the race.
I want to get sunburned by being in the desert and you know,
figuring out how the sun won't try and kill me by noon.
That's the Sahara.
And so that's how I go about it.
So part of your motivation is actually the perception by other people,
what you're doing.
Like understanding that what you're doing is so undeniable,
the volume that you're putting out and the intensity,
the intensity,
so undeniable.
Like I'll show you motherfuckers.
Yeah,
absolutely.
Wow.
That's so weird.
Even with people who like me,
like,
Yay Henry's here.
I'm like,
yeah,
I'm here.
Check it out.
Pitch.
So here's a place you won't go.
And not that I have any aggression towards these people.
I just,
I just want to burn brightly and it's not about money.
It's not about I'm better than you because I don't think I'm better than
anybody.
I just want to explode as much as possible.
And I think to my audience,
it's to their benefit.
He's like,
that dude's gonna go out there to a place I don't want to go and he's going to
come back with 10 grade photos and a story about how we nearly lost his foot.
It's great.
And like put me in coach.
That's the game I want to play.
That's what I go for.